senator bill cassidy of louisiana was
one of the 10 republican lawmakers who
met with president biden yesterday he
joins us now this morning
good morning to you senator it's very
good to see you i want to pick up with
senator collins who said
that the meeting was frank and it was
useful it was two hours so that seems
like a
quite a bit of time what was your take
on the meeting
exactly that and i would add a little
bit more it set the stage for going
forward
we obviously have disagreements and
numbers and the president said okay
we'll send you that which we are basing
our numbers on and we will
you know the senators will send the
administration the facts that we're
basing our numbers on
ideally if we have a common set of facts
we come to a common perception of of how
much need there is and therefore how
much to spend
and let's start with the numbers because
i i've heard team biden say this
that listen we went we didn't make these
numbers up willy nilly we went line by
line we want the moment to be met at
this particular time
and that that was the number they came
up to meet the need shouldn't they have
a good starting point of a number isn't
that a good idea
go big they say it is a good it is a
good idea but let's just take schools
they want 135 billion with a b for k
through 12.
now the cdc the centers for disease
control has said
you need about worst case scenario 455
dollars per student
to reopen schools congress has already
given
over a thousand dollars per student
almost
you know if you all added up two and a
half times more than the cdc would said
was necessary
now we put 20 billion in our package
which increases it even further
but you have to ask yourself if we're 2
to three to four times what the cdc
says is needed why do you need a hundred
and thirty five billion
i know senator president said he would
give us their numbers i know but
we could get all bogged down with the
numbers but i think the thing that
people keep
talking about is the need of the
american people who are hurting at this
time who need the money right now
and if we go with the republican plan
what's not to say that you know a couple
months from now we'll be right back
where we started
so why not start out now where people
are in need at this particular time
right now
let's look at this right let's look at
it congress has since we started in
march
if we took march all the way through
march with what the president is now
proposing
a family in louisiana could have
received reasonably
eighty to a hundred and ten thousand
dollars in benefits
most of which are tax-free now if we
don't include the president it's gonna
propose we'll be roughly around seventy
thousand to ninety
85 000 in tax-free benefits
now the median income for a family of
four in louisiana if i remember
correctly is somewhere between 50 and 60
000 before taxes so
we've really provided pretty well for
the american people if you look at the
indicators for the american family
credit card debt is down saving rates
are up
mortgage delinquency is down the
american family has and that's through
all
income quintiles so we've actually done
a pretty good job of meeting the needs
of the american people
it's more rhetoric to say that oh my
gosh the house is on fire
when in reality if you look at what the
data is from the fed
the families are doing pretty well based
upon what we've already done
well i think senator i think a lot of
families would say they're still
struggling
the democrats have signaled that they
can push this bill through
with or without republican votes is do
you see room for compromise here
i sure hope so there's been five coveted
relief packages passed with a republican
president and a republican senate
which have been bipartisan five of them
now all of a sudden the six
can't be bipartisan now that's a little
bit kind of ironic
because the president's message has been
a call for unity and bipartisanship
we had bipartisanship for the first five
and it's out the window on the sixth
uh it seems like we should be able to
come together but it would start with
having a common set of facts
and suppositions by which we can make
our decisions
senator i want to ask you about some
remarks that senate minority leader
mitch mcconnell
made calling out freshman republican
congressman marjorie taylor greene
he said a quote looney lies and
conspiracy theories
which are a cancer for the republican
party and our country that's what he
called
some of her remarks what is your
reaction to what he said
i agree with him entirely we have to
move
beyond what someone thinks might be true
because it's on the internet
into what is true as best as we can
understand it
and that is the only way we begin to
bridge the tribalism
that afflicts our country right now i'm
a doctor
my whole training is we need to base
things on facts
i agree wholeheartedly with what the
leader has said how do you move beyond
that
now you start with facts um i guess the
theme of this conversation has been that
it can't just be because you
want something to be true it has to be
what you know to be true
as best as you can know it um in my
devotional i was reading the imitation
of christ today
and in there it speaks about knowing
truth we need to know as best
we can truth and then make our decisions
but senator you know a lot of senators
aren't saying what you and mitch
mcconnell are saying out loud publicly
do you think there needs to be more
people who are saying out loud
we got to stick to the facts it seems
many people are running for the hills
instead of really saying
about her comments this is just
outrageous
what do you think should be done abroad
the leader said
the leader only said that last night so
i suspect you'll find a lot of senators
agreeing with that today
um but you know who said was it reagan
facts or pesky things they just tend to
you know hang with you
so the idea that we've got um all these
conspiracies that are being pushed on
the internet
uh as being absolutely truth hopefully
folks will pause
is it true best as i can tell it's not
and then we go forward
uh it's the way we come forward as a
country as well all right hopefully you
and others will speak up
because the facts really do matter here
thank you very much sir for your time
this morning we appreciate it